in the last video where we talked about
macro states we set up this situation
where I had this canister the cylinder
and had this movable ceiling I call that
a piston and the piston is being kept up
by the pressure from the gas in the
canister and it's being kept down by in
the last example I had a a rock or
weight on top and above that I had a
vacuum so essentially there's some force
per area or pressure being applied by
the bumps of the particles into this
piston and if this weight wasn't here
let's say it assumes that the piston
itself or this movable ceiling itself it
has no mass if that weight wasn't there
would just be pushed indefinitely far
because there'd be no pressure from the
vacuum but this weight is applying some
force on that same area downwards so
we're at some equilibrium point some
stability and we plotted that on on this
PV diagram right here I'll do it in
magenta so that's our state one that we
were in right there and then what I did
in the last video I just blew away half
of this block and as soon as I blew away
half of this block obviously the force
that's being applied by the block will
immediately go down by half and so the
gas will push up on it and it happened
so fast that all of a sudden the gas is
pushing up right when it happens the gas
near the top of the canister is going to
have lower pressure because it has less
pushing up against it the molecules that
are down here don't even know that I
blew away this block yeah it's going to
take some time and essentially the the
gas is going to push it up and then
maybe that it'll oscillate down and then
push it up and oscillate down a little
bit and it'll take some time eventually
do we get to we get to another
equilibrium state where we have a new
probably or definitely lower pressure
we definitely have a higher volume and
if we weren't well I won't talk too much
about it yet but we probably have a
lower temperature as well and this is
our new this is our new state and our
macro straights pressure and volume are
defined once we're at the new
equilibrium so we're right here
so my question in the last video was how
did we get here is there any way to have
defined a path to get from our first
date where pressure and and volume were
well defined because the system was in
thermodynamic equilibrium to get to our
second state and the answer was no
because between this state and this
state all hell broke loose I had
different temperatures at different
points in the in the mutton they in the
system I could have had different
pressure here then I had up here the
volume might have been fluctuating for a
moment-to-moment so when you're outside
of equilibrium and I had written down it
over I had written it down over there
you cannot define or you can't say that
those macro variables are well-defined
so there was no path that you could say
how we got from mere raíces how we got
from state 1 to state 2 you could just
say okay we were in some type of
equilibrium so we were in state 1 then I
blew away half the rock the pressure
went down the volume went up the
temperature also probably went down and
so I ended up in this other state once I
reached equilibrium and that's all fair
and good but wouldn't it have been nice
if there was some way if we could have
said look you know there's some way that
we got from this point to this point if
we could perform my little rock
experiment in a slightly different
manner so that all this hell didn't
break loose so that maybe at every point
in between our my macro variables are
actually defined so how could I do that
remember I said that the macro variables
the macro States whether it's pressure
temperature volume and there are others
but I say that these are only defined
when we are in a thermodynamic
equilibrium and that just means things
are stopped they've reached a stability
point that for example the temperature
is consistent throughout the system if
it's not consistent throughout the
system I shouldn't be talking about it
if the temperature is different here
than it is up here I shouldn't say that
the temperature of the system is X it's
different at different points so I
really can't make a well-defined
statement about temperature similar for
pressure or for or for volume because
the volume is also fluctuating but if I
perform that same experiment or that
same process I should call it let me
draw it again so I have my canister and
instead of starting with a rock just one
big rock
draw this is my piston right here at the
top of my is the movable ceiling of the
cylinder and I have some gas inside of
it instead of having just one big rock
like I had over here how about I start
with an equal weight of rock but let's
say I have a bunch of small pebbles that
add up to that same rock so this is a
bunch of one you know just a just a pile
of pebbles you can all you know maybe
there's sand they're super super duper
duper duper small right instead of just
blowing away half of the sand all at
once like I did with that rock over
there and immediately jumping to that
state and throwing the whole system into
this undefined state of non equilibrium
instead of doing that let me just do
things very slowly and very gently let
me just take out one grain of sand at a
time all right so if I just take out one
grain of sand and I do it and then I and
then I wait and so I took out an
infinitesimal amount of weight so what's
going to happen well this this Pistons
going to move up a little bit and let me
draw that so let me copy and paste it so
now my piston well since I just took out
one little piece of sand the force
pushing down will be a little bit less
with the pressure pushing down will be a
little less and so on my piston let me
see if I can draw this it will have
moved up let me erase it it will have
moved up a very infinitesimal
infinitesimally means an infinitely
small infinitely small amount right it
would have moved an infinitely small
amount of time and so you wouldn't have
thrown that system into this you know
havoc that I did this last time right of
course we haven't moved all the way here
yet but what we have done is we would
have moved from that point maybe to this
this other point right here that's just
a little bit just a little bit closer to
there I've just removed a little bit of
the weight so my pressure went down just
a little bit my volume went up just a
little bit temperature probably went
down and the key here is I'm trying to
do it in such small increments that as I
do it my
a system is pretty much super close to
equilibrium it's not in this that I'm
you know I'm just doing just slow enough
that at every step it achieves
equilibrium almost immediately or it's
it's almost in equilibrium the whole
time I'm doing it and then I do it again
and do it again and I'll just draw my
drawings a little less neat just for the
sake of time all right let's say I
remove another little little dot of sand
that's infinitely small mass and now my
my little piston will move with just a
little bit higher and I have remember I
have one less sand up here then I had
over here and then my volume if my gas
increases a little bit my pressure goes
down a little bit and I've moved to this
point here what i'm doing here is i'm
setting up what's called a quasi-static
process quasi-static process
quasi-static process and the reason why
it's called that is because almost
static it's almost an equilibrium the
whole time I'm just every time i move a
grain of sand i'm just moving a little
bit closer and obviously even a grain of
sand the reality is if i were to do this
in real life even a grain of sand on a
small scale is going to wreak a little
bit of havoc on my system this piston is
going to was going to go up and out a
little bit so i'll say oh let me just do
even a small or grain of sand and do it
even a little bit slower so that i'm
always in equilibrium so as you can
imagine this is kind of a theoretical
thing if i did an infinitely small
grains of sand and it just slow enough
so that it just gently gently moved from
this point to this point but we like to
think of it theoretically because it
allows us to describe a path because
remember why don't why am i being so
careful here why am i so careful to make
sure that the state the system is in
equilibrium the whole time when i get
from there to there because our macro
states are macro variables like pressure
volume and temperature are only defined
when we're in equilibrium so if i do
this process super slowly and super
small increments it allows me to keep my
pressure and volume and actually my
temperature of macro states at any point
in time so i could actually plot a path
so if i keep doing it small as well as
well i could actually plot a path
laughs to say how did I get from state 1
to state 2 on this on this PV diagram
and you might say you know how this is
this is all and I'll and I'll take a
little step back here I always found
this really confusing you know why do
why are people you'll see a lot of a lot
of talk and thermodynamic circles or
even your book about you know this is it
has to be a quasi-static process and you
know I was just wanting you know why are
people going through these pains to
describe this process where you're
removing sand after sand and the whole
point is because you want to get as
close to equilibrium the whole time
you're doing it as possible so that your
pressure and volume are defined the
whole time the reality is in the real
world you can never get something that's
continuously defined but you can just do
really really really small increments so
each small increment you're at some
equilibrium and if you're not happy with
that you can do even smaller increments
so at some point it's some limiting
point you do have some type of
continuous state change or while you're
always in equilibrium it's almost an
oxymoron because you're saying you're
static you're saying that your
your-your-your an equilibrium the whole
time but clearly you are also changing
the whole time you keep removing article
little pieces of sand but you remove
them just slow enough that all that
crazy up-and-down motion and all of the
flux and all of the weird temperature
changes don't happen and it just you
know just it just slowly slowly slowly
creeps up and this isn't this is the
reason why I'm even going through this
exercise is because it's key when we
start talking about thermodynamics and
these PV diagrams and we'll start
talking about Carnot engines and all of
that that we'd be able to at least
theoretically describe the path that we
take on this PV diagram and we wouldn't
have been able to do that if we can't
assume that we're dealing with a
quasi-static process now there's another
term that you'll hear in thermodynamic
circles that really I mean to me it
really I don't know I had trouble
comprehending it the first time I heard
it called reversible reversible and
sometimes these terms quasi static and
reversible or used interchangeably but
there is a difference quasi static
reversible processes are quasi static
and most quasi-static processes are
reverse
but there are a few special cases that
aren't but the idea of a reversible
process is something that happened so
slowly so in this example I took off a
grain of sand and I got to this state
but if I assume that no friction when
you know when this piston moved up a
little bit in the real world let's say
if these were you know this piston was
metal when this rubs against the
canister there'd be a little bit of
friction generated and a little bit of
energy would be dissipated as friction
or heat but in a reversible process
we're assuming the look this is
frictionless when anything happens in
the system when we go from this state
right here let's say this is state a to
state B so this is state a this is state
B when we go from this state to this
state one we're infinitesimally close to
equilibrium the whole time so all of our
macro states are well-defined and even
more when we move from one state to the
other there's no loss or dissipation of
energy so those are two there's those
are two important characteristics one
infinitely close to equilibrium at all
times and no loss of energy and the
reason why that matters for a reversible
process is because if we wanted if we
were sitting in state B we could just
add another grain of sand back in add
another grade of sand back in push down
this piston infinitely slow at an
infinitely small increment and get back
to state a right so that's why it's
called reversible you could you could be
at this point right here and take out a
little bit of sand and get to this point
right here but if you want since no
energy was lost you could add a little
bit of sand and get back to this point
right here now the reality in the real
world is if there is no such thing as a
perfectly reversible process there will
always be whenever you do anything there
will always be some energy or heat loss
to do lost to the process but so in the
real world if I moved down here if I
tried to put the sand back I would lose
some energy and probably get to a little
slightly different point but you don't
have to worry about that the important
takeaway from this video is that in that
this situation I described there there
was no intermediate macro state
variables because our system was in flux
it wasn't an equilibrium so if we wanted
to get intermediate states we just have
to essentially do this process it's
or the and so slow I mean it
theoretically would take you forever so
we can only approximate it but the sand
gives you an idea of what we're talking
about and if we did it slowly with these
infinitesimally small particles of sand
then we can define the state at every
point along the along the along the
process and that's why we call it quasi
static because at any point it's almost
static it's almost an equilibrium so our
pressure volume and temperatures can be
defined and then if we add to that the
notion that we haven't lost any heat
when we're going in one direction or or
another we could say it's reversible
because if we took a piece of sand away
we can always add a little a little bit
of sand next now actually with that said
let me give you the one example if maybe
a quasi-static not actually I'll save
that for a future video anyway hopefully
you understand that these are these
these are two concepts that used to
really confuse me and hopefully this
this this clears it up a little bit and
I think more than what it is I think you
know the first time I read about them
like okay well what's the big deal the
big deal is it allows you to define
every your your macro States for every
state in between these two states that
you care about when you just did it as a
regular kind of non quasi-static process
in between you don't know what happened